hey everybody its Jessie
sorry I couldn't stream yesterday I
wasn't feeling good actually not really
feeling that great today but I had to
come in add an important meeting this
morning that I didn't want to skip and I
had some login info for a server that I
needed to do some work on and I didn't
have the login info at home I I just had
it on my computer here so I had to come
in so if I sound a little bit off today
it's because I'm not feeling well I
apologize in advance today we're going
to do a live search feature so I've done
this before but not with react or I
should say I have done this on a react
site before but I kind of just adapted
what I had done from other sites which
was in jQuery and I didn't really make
it you know proper react code so today I
want to try to do it would be in a more
correct way within react and and not
used to jQuery before basically I was
adding and removing elements from the
Dom with jQuery which is not really
great to do and react so I don't want to
do that
so I'm not sure how long this will take
or if it'll work since I haven't done it
this way before but the basic concept is
you have an input a text input the user
types on what as soon as they type in a
few letters then you send a request to
the WordPress API searching for any any
post of that post type that you're
looking for which in our case would be
the resources search for any posts that
contains that string and then you get a
response back and you can see the cards
pop up as you're typing so usually I
like to do maybe like
once you get three characters in then it
will refresh with maybe a timeout so
we're not sending like a million API
calls when someone's typing but like I
said I've got that working on a few
sites before but not exactly in this way
so that's the goal and then the last
show we were trying to get the what was
it all the masonry layout to work so let
me let me just show you that actually
right I was working on this this page
right before I started and I changed
something in it broke the page and I'm
just trying to look at what I changed I
don't really know what I would have done
it little broken the page but let me
take out I know I added something down
here I'll just take this whole section
out for now I don't really think it
would have caused any problems but I
just want to get it working so I can
show you
all right so let me bring this over on
the screen let me find a
there we go
all right so I can't take credit for
this Fabian who was watching must have
been watching on gosh what day was it
today's Wednesday so Monday sorry
must've been watching on Monday notice
that I was having trouble getting this
to work with the tabs actually submitted
a pull request which was awesome and you
could see some of the code for that and
I'll show to you again what he did so
thank you very much that saved me a lot
of time and frustration from trying to
figure out why I can get it to work and
let me just show you really quick
basically what what he had done and I
don't know that I can even explain it
properly since since he did he did it if
you're watching Fabian and you want to
explain it more in the live chat please
feel free
so he took let me see where we're at
actually let me just let me show you the
get diff because that'll make it so much
easier for you all to see see I'm at
I was on a different was it on a
different branch yeah us that shouldn't
matter so I
alright let me make this a lot bigger so
you can see ok so some of this stuff I
had just taken this out so he's bringing
this component back in if you remember
we were using that react masonry
component so - he's setting the state
here basically for which tab is is
active so the alt tab is active right
off the bat and then you can see down
below that'll change based on what tab
is clicked but the and he's gotten rid
of a lot of this stuff because I was
failing to use masonry properly so this
is the bulk of what was added so you can
see the component the components are now
here okay well it's the the template
kind of for this component exists up
here as a constant its variable and we
have all the tabs here key value pairs
and here we go okay so here's where we
used to have this template I could show
you here so we used to have this
template all right here and it was just
looping through everything once the once
the API code was made not only that but
we had had it four times here for each
of our four options now we just have it
once okay and it loops through so this
is the the tabs so it goes through the
tabs and
it renders the components for that tab
inside here without having to render all
of them in infor here so pretty awesome
solution actually shortened up things
quite a bit if you could see took out
big chunks of code so cleaned everything
up a lot and in addition to making
masonry work so I really appreciate that
and this is on github if you want to
take a look at it kind of go in more
depth I don't want to take too much more
time on it just because you know if if
you read the what this stream was
supposed to be about and you're waiting
for me to do that you know I don't want
to disappoint
so really awesome thanks again Fabian
and let's get back to to get back here
uh one other thing Fabian did that was
also awesome was he he pointed out if
you remember on Monday I had some like
static on my a month with my mic I got a
new mic and I thought so it was wrong my
mic and he had pointed out in the
comments that maybe I had my phone next
to the mic and that was causing the
static and in fact I did have my phone
right next to the mic and when I had
used it earlier from home I did not have
my phone next to it so I think that was
the problem let me know if you hear the
static again just in case it wasn't that
but I'm almost positive that that was
the issue so anyway Fabian is probably
one of my favorite people right now it's
since he's helped me out so much in the
last few days I just checked the lab
chat for the first time sorry I kind of
forgotten about it a lot of people
saying hi so hey everybody thanks for
watching see a lot a lot of new people
so really cool ok Fabian's washingto
awesome
let's see
all right awesome Patrick linked the
github page that shows what I was just
showing you there what Fabian had done
in case you want to check it out all
right so let me let me go in here and
just show you what what I was trying to
do and I haven't really gotten that much
done you can see like I typed the name
for a function of where things are going
to happen and then I had also tried to
put in a an input and I just copy and
pasted this from the documentation for
materialise you can see it's even says
first name which is not not what I want
I want it to be searched and I was just
trying to change it so that it would be
valid in react so I did you use like
class name and HTML for instead of just
four and I don't I don't remember if I
have to change
oops there we go I knew there was there
had to be something else that I was
missing and actually that I don't even
need this class so I'm going to get rid
of that
all right for some reason when I had
pasted this in at first it caused the
page to break so that's why I just
pulled it out so I can show you what was
going on but now actually let me give my
page up here alright so that is not
broken now not the best looking thing
but I'm not worried about style right
now all I'm worried about is we have
somewhere where I can put input into
okay awesome first step completed I
think I'm going to make this make this
bigger first of all so you can see and
it might be easier as we whoops as we go
they're going to make that maybe half
the page and that way you can see the
changes as we're making them on the site
okay that'll work let me know if I need
to increase the font size even more
all right sorry I just got I just got a
message from a co-worker I just want to
make sure it wasn't some emergency
okay it's a it's a minor problem I can
check it out after the stream all right
so let's now that we have that working I
want to add I've never actually tried to
do this particular thing in react so if
anyone watching has done this and I'm
messing this up let me know but I was I
was checking out briefly beforehand how
to handle like key press events and
react so I think I can just use like on
on key up I was trying to figure out
what how exactly it supposed to be typed
in terms of case so I'm guessing it's
something like that
okay Rob had a question a live chat is
is there a link to the first stream for
this so that the entire like so the
first one where I actually started to
work on this site is on my channel and
it's called I think it's called building
a website as fast as I can because that
way that was the original goal and then
we got some extra time and now since the
site's launched we have even more time
to add extra features ok so I'm just
going to try to call what did we call
this is it this these console I know
there are better ways to test but the
console log is just it's just so nice
and familiar and it it shows up in the
console well on the video so ok so what
I want to see happen is
great that should be it
broke wouldn't Anki up is not oh yeah
shoot that's not what I called it I
called it search get search results
there we go
alright not I don't know what that was
about maybe I did something and it broke
so what we want to do I want to inspect
this so I can see what's going on here
that's that's Texas definitely big
enough mmm that's not really what we
wanted it did say it did say key up
quite a few times but that's not not
what I wanted here
hmm I'm gonna let me clear this just to
make sure okay yeah it's definitely not
working the way I wanted it to refresh
and see what we're getting it once maybe
I'm using the wrong the wrong syntax I'm
gonna go I'm just gonna check it out
maybe I have to case it wrong maybe it
needs to be I'm just going to try this
quick because if this is this the
problem and that should solve it very
quickly now all right okay so it is
supposed to be that case let me refresh
again is to see now definitely not not
working all right let's see what's going
on in
okay this is the input I don't want this
placeholder to either let me get rid of
that while I'm in here okay so that's
what I'm what I'm saying so Sebastian a
live chats and it is on key up
I'm calling am I missing
I mean I'm not crazy here right this is
normally how we call how we call a
function and make sure get search
results console doc right yeah that's
that should work
yep for some reason all I'm getting here
is a key up it's constantly key up once
when i refresh the page and then it's
not working after that all right so let
me go to the documentation or Stack
Overflow oh okay
thank you for that and sorry it took so
long there's like a delay probably like
a minute or so so Anton thank you
Anton said don't invoke the function so
I figured it was something with that it
just didn't look right to me but I I
just couldn't figure out exactly what it
was and that was it
alright so let's check this out now oops
smooth this over Kia yes okay so nice
that's exactly what we wanted
okay so I mean that was kind of the easy
part
I knew that that was possible I just
hadn't actually done a non-key up in
react before so just needed to get well
I just needed to know the capitalization
here and this invoking the function was
just a dull mistake on my part okay so
now we need to do is within here we need
to fetch the data from the wordpress API
and not just any data it has to be it
has to take the value of this input or
this input is it takes to take the value
of this input and then search for that
then it has to base what I wanted to do
is render cards based on that search
into here and then also the same cards
would be rendered you know when you
click on these it wouldn't it wouldn't
be all the audio anymore it would simply
be veal category or the the resources in
the audio category that matched that
search so maybe I should
let me put this in whoops I'm gonna put
this in here sometimes it's helpful at
least for me to kind of just put in
plain you know English what I want to
accomplish so I don't forget because I
have it in my head right now but once I
get into it I might skip a step so step
one would be get input get input value
and nope and step two is make API call
based on value and then we want to
render cards from okay so that's it
basically we can break that down into
three steps that's what we need to do
all right I just checked the the
analytics for this we had like almost a
hundred viewers right off the bat and
then it dropped down an hour at like
just below 60 so guess I guess I lost a
lot of people this is about where is
kind of back up to normal we were a
little bit low on Monday but I didn't
realize that Apple's all that stuff was
going on so that might explain it all
right so first we need to get that value
on key up so where is it at I keep
losing the the input you make this a bit
bigger well there we go
okay so usually input give an idea of
search okay so I'm just going to do this
I don't know if there's a better way to
do this in react but I'm just going to
go get Boop's documents the good
elements addy and we want the search
element and I think it's just value
we'll see um
let's see what that does and let's say
this let's search time equal ennui we
may as well bring back our console log
oops okay so basically I'm going to
narrate a little bit I know some of you
in here are way past you missed and our
answers Patrick just said I'm sorry
Patrick I'm not sure what you are
referring to oh I missed an R and search
haha alright awesome that's one of the
really great things about live streaming
is you know normally when when you code
you make little mistakes like that you
don't realize it and then you try to run
the code and you know depending on what
you're trying to do sometimes it takes a
while to figure out what the mistake was
but in this case you know right now I
have you know 64 people watching me do
this so somebody is going to catch my
mistakes early enough so that it doesn't
really mess things up so thanks Patrick
I appreciate that um you know my ID did
I also mess up get element by ID oh you
were just telling me that was where it
was in okay awesome uh sorry if you're
watching this recording later I'll try
to do my best to let you know what is
being said in the live chat but
occasionally I do just respond and I
forget about that so try to try to watch
it live if you can next time but I I
know not everybody can because of the
time zone difference
I was I was about to say something and I
got distracted oh I wanted to say I'm
going to narrate this and kind of
explain what I'm doing in a little bit
more depth because I know that
there are some people that are beyond me
that watch this and they help me a lot
but there are some people who are just
beginning and I want to make sure that
they understand as much as possible
what's going on so for instance like
Taylor and the live chat said just
learning to code so not it doesn't
really know a lot of the stuff that's
going on so I'm going to do that so
sorry if this is really basic for you
but anyway uh this let is just it's just
like a variable but this is kind of a
new or a JavaScript way to do this so
there are some advantages to using let
instead of just ver which you would
normally use not really going to go into
that right now
but in general most of the times we use
very you could use let and it'll work
just fine it does not work in older
browsers though so you have to be
careful about that and you have to
transpile the code so anyway this is
just the vanilla JavaScript way to get
an element on the page by ID so that
that input tag that we had down here I'm
not going to scroll down to right now we
gave it an ID of search so now we're
just getting that and what I want to get
is the value from that so I want to get
whatever the user typed in and I'm just
going to console.log this just to see to
make sure that we're getting what the
correct value and that I've set this up
right at this point is pretty basic so
it should work so I'm going to save that
in case I haven't already and let's get
our console ready and whoa you know I
use a function did I spell that Oh
should it not be should not be D or
should it be no it is right it is Eddie
what am i doing
two equal documented I'm sure somebody's
going to tell me in that in the live
chat what's wrong because it's probably
some silly mistake
man if I have to look up get element by
ID I'm going to be going to be
embarrassed by that is it a lowercase T
okay get up I don't know what's up with
my it probably just autocorrected
because I had spelled it wrong to begin
with so that's what kind of threw me
whenever the when I went to go change it
in it autocorrected right back alright
thanks for that was in the process of my
other screen I'm just looking it up I
mean that's how it goes you know you
can't have all the syntax memorized
although that one I use pretty often so
that that surprised me that could
remember that but you can see this is
working just like we want it to work so
every time we change it we get that
that's actually cool effect I like that
it looks cool alright so step one is
completed let's see make now we need to
make an API call okay so here's what I
know how to do an API call with fetch on
the client-side but here's what I'm
wondering about I am importing fetch
here somewhere here where am i important
is do not need to import it
I thought I had to import isomorphic
fetch it's imperative I just couldn't
find it okay so I'm importing this
Eiffel isomorphic fetch and then I'm
using it here and get initial props but
this runs server-side ok so that's why
I'm using that's the term isomorphic
means it runs on the server or on the
client
this runs server-side but it also runs
client-side like when we do our
client-side routing and we go between
pages this this will also run that's why
you know we still have the data on the
pages I mean I know there's caching and
serviceworker and things but even if we
didn't have all that this was still
running we'd still get data I would just
run in the client side but I'm I don't
want to use this outside of this get
initial props function because next j/s
which is what we're using you know we're
running react with that I think they do
some things behind the scenes to know
whenever to use this you know how to use
this on the server and the client I'm
afraid if I put this down here and try
to run on the client I'm not going to
get the right results so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to try to use
fetch normally how I would use it on the
on the client side even if I wasn't
using react and I'm going to see how
that works if anybody has has any input
on that idea let me know but that's
that's the next step that's what I'm
going to try to do here uh let me
actually let me copy and paste
cuz that's always faster so I have I
thought I had it up already let me show
you funny maybe I had it up why did I
have this up this is a previous here we
go this is a project I had done earlier
a few months ago and so anyway so I had
this that I already made so I figured
why not reuse that so let's see
I don't need this
okay alright so basically what it's
going to do is I'm going to call I can
copy like some of this stuff
I am going to change this we're going to
leave resources but we're basically
going to leave this but I need to add in
that search parameter I don't really
need to add it right now because I need
to test just to make sure that I can
call so I'm not going to complicate it
by adding in a search which I could mess
that up
bet it better to just do one change at a
time and then at least in testan at
least you know it least easier to find
out what went wrong
so basically when I call get JSON said
how it goes yeah so when I call get JSON
all right I'm going to pass it a URL
which is going to be the combination of
these two so let's just do that now in
JSON and tough to write this I don't
know if I've to write this when I'm when
I'm up here but I'm gonna do it anyway
if you didn't already know you're
joining for the first time I don't claim
to be an expert on any of this
especially react because I've only done
a few projects with react so if it seems
like at times I'm just kind of winging
it it's because I am I'm learning on the
go but that's how the show is about just
watching me and my normal job and I
think normally with developers a lot of
what you do is just learning on the go
at least that's been my experience so I
hope that you all learn something from
this but I actually learned a lot from
you as well as a kind of struggle
through this so if you're expecting like
a very detailed and thought-out tutorial
or something that's not what you're
going to get in these videos which those
videos are awesome but I'm not really
knowledgeable enough about this to be
the person to do a video like that at
least not yet maybe one day I'll be
knowledgeable enough
okay and I am I'm like I'm tempted to
just console love this whole thing this
whole day so they why not I kind of want
to see what that will look like actually
I need to probably save this but I could
actually probably use constant here
right I'm not going to change it right
now but just just for I mentioned before
what let was you can also use this
instead of air and it's constant this is
like if you have something you want to
be immutable like you don't want it to
change a variable that won't change you
don't want it to be allowed to change
later on within that same scope you use
Const and I had used let it let is like
my default go-to because it usually
works for everything but now that I'm
looking at this this isn't going to be
changed within you know it's gonna every
time this is called this will be changed
but you know it's not like going to be
changed down here within the same
function call so I probably could just
use Const for this and I'm just going to
do it for consistency since I'm already
using it and now I'm going to make this
do I want to call this data in here
we're calling this data on state a for
now maybe I shouldn't we just call it WP
data for WordPress data and also if
you're joining in you're wondering about
the WordPress API part I'll show you
what gets returned from the API and
I think in the last video I did I did go
into a little bit how I set up the API
some of the custom things I was doing so
if you're a little lost on that you can
check out the last video I may do like a
full video on on the WordPress API at
some point if there's enough interest in
it all right so this set up I think we
have this note missing one thing
all right let's see okay in the live
chat I mean I haven't checked a lot yet
in a while so I'm going to just check it
here just just for a minute see if
there's any questions all Sebastian try
to react on a project with with next to
jQuery scaling you okay uh KEB KEB Ian I
think I'm not sure how to pronounce that
but cabbie in 6020 says I think you can
use a weight just fine even the client
side since the next auto compiles es 7
es 5 that's good to know if this doesn't
work off a problem with this I will
definitely go back and switch to that
also
I might just switch to it at some point
if I have time just I think it would
look better if I was using it in the
same way you know on the same you know
the same component
and cabbie and says I use constant Ida
fault
and use let only to denote I'm going to
change it okay that's actually
interesting I never thought about it
that way so I had just mentioned that my
default is usually let and then I only
use cost when I think I need it but he's
still in the opposite that's honestly
probably a safer way to code it is to
use Const by default and then that way
there's less chance of you accidentally
changing changing cost Oh Kevin also
says you can change the properties of a
constant object and even at new ones you
just can't replace the whole object with
another thing an mentions that WP date
is a promise you have to either a weight
or a thin on it good good call I thank
you for pointing that out
and you know what I actually did do that
was it here I am doing that here what is
this one searches at some point and I'm
just going to look at this this is how I
implemented the same search thing with
some extra features and things with
jQuery stuff so if you want to look at
it I just want to check one thing out
here
um okay yeah I did do that here um I
just want to double check how I handled
that here and what I did inside you okay
[Music]
this is like I don't know there's so
much here that like obviously I have
these two dudes left in here and
different things but it definitely works
and I did exactly what I wanted it to do
I wish I would have had time to refactor
this though I look back on it now and
I'm like yeah it works but it's kind of
a mess just don't always have the time
before I have to launch to get all those
things in order
all right then okay where we at
all right so let's take this out for now
so I'm do get you some more if you from
and then I can just chain it with a then
right let me see how I did this here
well guys name the date of this I guess
I can and now I can
okay now I'm going to console.log the
data there just for now I mean obviously
we're going to do other stuff with it
later on thanks thanks for catching that
so you normally I test a bunch of times
and then troubleshoot but now I like I
can't even can't even hit save fast
enough before you all catch my mistake
so thanks for that I'm sure it is
speeding speeding things up for me all
right let's see what's going on where's
my console there we go all right so
let's see I'm a little bit not really
sure about how I did fetch here yeah and
it looks like Oh something was happening
cannot really probably get JSON of no
hmm
well that's interesting
okay Patrick says console dir console
about table will be better
actually that's new for me I've never
heard of console table I've never used
it
I'm going to use that as I've never seen
that that's cool and what did I do
maybe is it because I use this and I
need to was that with that I'm trying to
read this error message cannot get
property get JSON of null okay let's see
okay then why oh I wonder if this got
messed up since I'm in here and I have
to I do this before
okay relaunches get JSON you Oh
maybe this get inside geez
oh good call cabin you are just like on
point today with catching these things
so I I had copied and pasted these two
functions and and didn't modify them at
all but it makes sense like if I have to
call normally you have to call this
interact component if you're going to
call these functions so I didn't do that
because I'm calling this gate function
inside this get JSON so that may be the
issue okay so it should be this yes all
right that might fix it let's try it out
and Fabian also said this was the other
thing that I was worried about it's it's
not mine this isn't binded to the class
so so this in this case is not referring
to like like when I called this down
here it's not referring to the same this
so I used to buying how should I bind
this I know there's something that you
can use an arrow function and it binds
it does something with binding I don't
use arrow functions often enough to
remember what exactly happens with the
binding is anybody know Romo Maddie
right when I was saying this he puts a
an arrow function and he said change get
search results to an arrow function for
Autobahn so awesome okay and with syntax
that's it
I'm no good at remembering syntax and
this is something I use constantly so
I'm like always always having to look it
up I don't know if is it like that for
any of you
you just frequently have to look up
syntax stuff and for that there we go
and it happens like at least for me it's
so easy to lose to lose it like let's
say if I like one on vacation I didn't
do any coding for a week it feels a
little bit weird getting back into it
like things that you used to type
constantly now you have to think about
again I don't know I thought that
happened happen to me
certainly and since I'm using this here
I should probably bind that as well
right let's try it on huh oops no I did
it wrong didn't construct that's ugly
guess what what did I do that was wrong
here
Oh obviously right
you
all right
I should probably explain arrow
functions for the people that are kind
of new let me test this first just to
see if I did it right yes
okay awesome and actually uh thanks
Patrick for letting me know about this
wow this is a lot for letting me know
about the console table instead of
console.log look at that that looks
really nice that's so much easier to
read than what you would normally get
I mean you normally get like this thing
with you'd have to keep opening it up it
would be nested so very nice I don't
alright so normally it would look like
this actually you wouldn't get in a
table format great and in fact we are
getting the data that we want awesome so
step two is almost finished okay because
we are getting the data that we want
this is all working properly but we
actually want to do a search based on
what was typed in that's why like I was
getting a bunch of data for everything
even though I just typed in a string of
nonsense I shouldn't have gotten results
for that right so I'm going to I'm going
to go back to here to get because this
will probably the easiest way for me to
find how I did the search
wait a sec now that wasn't it it was in
this one okay so here's the search URL
okay so basically all I have to do is in
this case I was actually using multiple
post type so I'm going to do I'm going
to need to do this pretty soon so maybe
tomorrow or something I'll do a video
and highlight this this is really cool
what lets you get multiple post types
obviously just like it says within
within this one call so in this case I
wanted to search basically nearly
everything on the site I don't want to
do that here so I'm not going to do all
that but so it'd be cool to point that
out so I'm going to take this and put
that in right here okay so we want to
put the search term here
and I'm going to use template literal
syntax and accidie so let me let me do a
little little e^x six lesson here not
that I know what I'm talking about too
much with this but I do use these so
arrow functions this is like shorthand
way to do functions sometimes you can
see like you know I did have the the
parentheses over here like in a normal
function and I add URL in there but now
I moved it out here and you have this
little this what's called arrow function
you have this little thing here okay um
this works differently inside arrow
functions I'm not going to get too deep
into it because I'm not confident that I
could explain this without messing
something up but I don't want to mislead
you so you know check out arrow
functions but basically within react I
usually use arrow functions like in this
case to make sure that this means what I
want it to mean I see arrow function
used in a lot of other ways
so there's definitely you know other
reason to use them even possibly just to
make the code a bit more concise and
then down here I use template literal
syntax and I know I've talked about this
before in my live streams but if you've
never seen me seen this dream or heard
me talk about it
these were just like a single or double
quotes so anything in here is a string
but if you want to use JavaScript inside
here either a variable or any other part
of JavaScript that you want to use you
put a dollar sign and a curly bracket
whatever your JavaScript is in here and
then you end it with another curly
bracket and now you're back into string
mode so where's normally you would have
to do something like this where you
would put your your JavaScript and then
you would do this and you'd finish out
your string right this is not that bad
but imagine if I was going to put in a
lot of different variables
here it could get super long really fast
so this is nice the other nice thing you
can do is I can do this and put that in
there and that that's okay
right that that'll work I can actually
put I've used these template literals to
actually do like HTML templates before
and I've had a huge chunk of HTML here
with variables in there and used it
basically insights that I've kind of
done try to do like single page app
style sites but using jQuery so I don't
try to do that anymore because it kind
of gets a mess after a while and if it
gets complex but if you have something
simple it's definitely doable and
template literals makes it way more
doable than normal at least that was my
experience with it all right let me I'm
gonna check the live stream really quick
Umberto's says what is this vacation I
immensely what on vacation
I actually am going to go on vacation
the week after next so I don't know if
I'll be able to do streams from vacation
my wife probably will not want me to to
do any streams but I don't know if the
Internet is fast enough maybe I doubt it
fast enough though and let me see I have
a few other comments here
okay Burma Maddox says wait how is this
geturl working when it isn't bound to
the class like the other methods had to
be I don't know I'm not easy uh it it
works obviously it works so I'm not
going to question it right now let's get
it all working and we'll say maybe if
anybody else you know wants to take a
crack at answering that question go
ahead
[Music]
Shane asked how far should you be
through the front end cert program
through free code camps run insert
program before you try learning react
and Patrick says learn plenty of
JavaScript first yes I would agree
JavaScript um react is I mean it's
JavaScript heavy like you know
everything is within JavaScript right
this is all so yeah so definitely
JavaScript uh it's a big help
I'm I'm not really a good example I
never got through the front end program
in pre code camp before I started doing
react stuff and now I mean that was
basically like I just got really busy
with work and had to I mean I had to do
things for clients you know I needed
things to work so I kind of just didn't
have that much time anymore
and I wasn't at one point I was really
disciplined and I spent an hour at least
an hour every day doing some type of
training and then I got busy and I
wouldn't wasn't disciplined about it so
I just kind of moved on I I really do
want to finish everything in the free
code camp curriculum at some point I
just need to I just need to put my foot
down and say like all right first thing
in the morning you know I'm going to do
this I'm going to take an hour and I'm
not going to check my email or anything
like that and get distracted so it'll
happen one day I guess but so it's
possible to do this stuff without
getting through the front end
certification it will definitely be easy
year for you if you get through I know
my react there are parts of react that
are still a struggle for me but when I
first started working with it it was it
was super hard for me to understand what
was going on okay so now that we're
going to have this search term going
here let's just test it up so I'm going
to save that and what we should get now
is we should get our results back and
we'll see them we'll see our results but
they will only be the results that we
get for searching so we'll try let's see
the we'll just type in some nonsense
again let me clear this because that's a
lot so actually that's weird how did I
get that from that nonsense hmm
that should not have happened like that
I should have gotten should have gotten
some nonsense okay so this might
actually be useful to people who haven't
seen this yet to actually see what the
result is in the browser and this will
also be useful to me to make sure that
what I'm doing is actually the right way
to do it so search and I don't know okay
that that returned nothing which is what
it should have returned but let me check
let me just do something like the okay
awesome
so that is actually working the way we
want it to if you can see like this is
what we get back from the wordpress api
it's a JSON format and i'm specifying
what i want so i said i only want the
title and I only want advanced custom
fields normally you'd get a lot more
data than this but I don't need that
data so I don't I don't want to I don't
want to send back okay so we get the
title and then these are custom fields
that I've created and I've used the
plug-in advanced custom fields to do
that and another plug-in to actually
expose the fields to the API or through
the API so that's working so we know
that this is working I'm not exactly
sure why it wasn't working search what
wasn't working before let's try it again
let me do a hard refresh and try this
again occasionally when I'm the next
comes with hot module reloading so you
don't like it just refreshes and you
don't have to like you hit save and
stuff changes on the page right you
don't have to refresh but occasionally I
find that sometimes I change something
here and it doesn't exactly work right
away I have to do
reload so I'm not sure why that happens
but sometimes you will have to do that
alright I want to try let's see okay
cool so I'm not getting anything there
which is what we want there we go
but now we have that so nothing put a
foot type in word okay so that's really
cool so if you see if it's if it's
nonsense you know obviously we're not
getting anything back and we are getting
something back if it's a real word so
great so that part is working just like
we wanted to the only other thing that
I'd like to do with this is I I'd like
to do two things to slow this down one I
don't want it to work with just one or
two one or two characters I mean there's
not really any meaningful words that are
only two characters long so you wouldn't
need to search for it like you wouldn't
need to search for of or is or you know
there's not going to be character like
that so I want to make it so that it
only works if you have at least three I
also want to make it so that I think
there ought to be maybe some delay so
that you know people didn't wouldn't
just let's say I just hold it in this
key actually I can't hold it in that's
interesting I don't know what's doing
that but let's say I just want to
impress this really fast like this just
made a bunch of calls I don't want that
to happen I don't want to make all these
calls to the API over and over again
so I do want there to be some sort of
timeout I don't want it to be too long
because then it'll seem like it's not
responsive to the user and somebody
typing fast you know maybe it will take
a second before it before it happens so
I might have to play with the timing of
that to see what's what's reasonable in
terms of you know like how many
milliseconds
I wait before I let it happen again but
basically step two is is complete aside
from that little bit of fine-tuning that
I can always do later they're not that's
not really essential to this working
those are just things that will help
prevent you know too many calls being
made the site actually is not getting
very much traffic now so I'm not worried
about like anything crashing or slowing
down a lot
I checked the analytics yesterday and it
looked weird so it basically looked like
a spike in traffic a spike a spike a
spike a spike right and I was like why
is there spikes in traffic and then I
looked at the time of each spike guess
what time of day each spike was for this
for this site for the live version of
this site let's see I'm going to give
you a few minutes to to guess what what
time what would be happening at some
point in the day where I would get huge
spikes in traffic on that site
well while you think about that for a
second I'm going to catch up on the live
chat bromo Matic says I finished the
entire front insert before touching
react it was a good experience getting
used to doing everything in the Dom with
jQuery slash JavaScript before relying
on frameworks I agree with that
like I like I said before I didn't do it
that way and I think it was harder for
me because I didn't do it that way and I
I still want to go back and finish it
and I think it'll help even now having
worked with react I think it still will
help me grow mimetic also says maybe
it's changed but I don't think it's
changed yet but the data visualization
course was when you started doing
projects and react for the free code
camp I think you're right I know there's
the beta version of free code camp
that's not it's not out yet so the order
might be
different there I haven't looked at the
beta stuff for a long time so I don't
know where it's at now I can't remember
where it was that last time I looked at
it John asks how come use fetch instead
of AK cos or jQuery for Ajax calls and
Patrick answers fetch is the newer
replacement that is 100% correct
yeah fetch is newer the only reason you
wouldn't use fetching in my opinion
fetches the easiest out of any other way
I've ever used to make to make calls
like that it's it's just so much shorter
to do and you know it returns promises
that are easy to work with so I
recommend using FETs the only reason you
wouldn't use fetch is if for some reason
you had to support an older browser and
you you couldn't use the polyfill so
normally like you would you would have a
polyfill that you would use to make
fetch work on older browsers and
actually I need to double check because
since I use this version of fetch
instead of this I may have to include a
polyfill somewhere since this is all
just on the client off to see I don't
know what this will actually get turned
into by next so maybe I won't maybe I
will have to check that maybe it would
be better just to use this yeah so I
didn't think about that before I'll have
to keep that in mind and make sure I
test this on a browser where I know
fetch doesn't work and make sure that it
works
all right so Sebastian says 2:00 p.m.
stream time right that is the answer to
the question so in Rowan says it was us
yeah so it turns out that most of the
traffic to this site at this point I
mean it's it just launched Desmond been
live and it hasn't been advertised quite
as much as it could have but the
majority of the traffic to the site at
this point is from you all when I'm
live-streaming you go to the site and
you check it out and that's the traffic
so that the site's really been getting
low traffic so my original point was
simply I'm not that worried about too
many calls messing up the site because
there's not a lot of traffic right now
okay but at some point if it gets a lot
more traffic that will be an issue so
I'd rather just kind of deal with it now
or at least at some point you know
within maybe this week or next week deal
with it and not have to worry about it
later if you remember last week we added
load balancing but that was only for the
react part of the site remember the site
has two parts there's the react part
which exists on one server and then the
WordPress part exists on another server
there's only one WordPress server so
even though there's to react sites on
two different servers that we're
balancing the load between all the calls
the API calls still go back to one
WordPress so that's a point where it
could slow things down so I do want to
make sure that we're doing everything we
can to speed that up and there's some
caching and things that are that are
going to happen there's already some
caching in place with the react site and
there's some caching that I'm going to
put in place on WordPress once we get
the content filled out a bit and that
should take the load down but when it
comes to the searches these are usually
unique you know they're probably going
to be some terms that are frequently
searched but you know as I'm typing in
and I type in like a partial word it's
like you know nobody's going to search
for that normal
right so that's not going to be cash
odds are no one search for that before
it's not going to be cash so it's not
really going to help with caching so if
there's anything that's going to slow
this down at the level of WordPress it's
going to be the search at least that's
what I think if anyone else has any
insight into that let me know but that's
that's kind of the only place that I
know of at this point that could really
really slow it down all right
okay roll and says fetch is just better
than xhr anything this or late last year
has fetched yet I I agree definitely
with her on fetches fetches way easier
to use
Campion says isomorphic fest requires
note fetch in the server and a fetch
polyfill on the client so I'm wondering
if next takes care of that polyfill
already because we're using isomorphic
fetch will that then take care of it I
shouldn't really worry about it because
I can I can test it very easily when I
need to by looking at batted an older
browser so I'm not going to worry about
it right now
I'm not going to put this live before I
test it and I'm definitely going to test
it in some older browsers just to
double-check that so not going to worry
about it right now just know that that
is an issue if you are using fetch
depending on what you're using it may or
may not work in every browser so in this
case it could be that next automatically
puts that polyfill in and it does work
but if you are building this site with
something else or just kind of a static
site you would need to include the
polyfill on your own I have included on
some of my other projects so if you
check out my github page let me think if
there's a project actually I don't know
I think they might be private repos so I
don't know if I can think of a project
that I've done recently where I use the
polyfill for fetch and it's not private
I will let you know or maybe put the
link in the description or something but
it's not that hard to do just I'm you
know you can look up fetch polyfill or
something like that it's pretty easy to
add to your project I don't want to
dismiss it and say it's easy I know
people say that a lot and I don't want
anybody to feel bad if it's not easy for
you it's easy if you're used to doing
things like that if you've never done
anything like that before then of course
it's it's not easy
you know it wouldn't be easy for me the
first time I did it so I don't want to I
don't want to make it seem like it's
it's really like anybody should be able
to do it right away because that's
certainly not the case all right
[Music]
Burton asks is this sublime it is Adam
and Hertz on Sebastian answered says
Adam art son says looks cool but takes
ages to start yeah you're correct but
you know how I get around that problem
I never close it or shut off my computer
so here's here's a tip here's the number
one lesson for today if you want Adam to
perform better never close it because
once it's open it's not bad
um I am joking a little bit with that
one but it is true that I rarely ever
close it so I don't notice the slowness
of it because I'm never really starting
it okay let's go on right now we need to
render the cards okay so that's the last
thing and okay not bad the streams been
how long is the stream with one all
right an hour in 15 minutes you see the
assignment is okay we still have alright
we still 44 viewers I say we should go
for it I was thinking about just ending
it and doing this tomorrow but I say we
go for we still have a decent amount of
viewers so if you hear me just randomly
laughs it's probably something in the
live chat so I'm not insane especially
if you're watching this later on it's
just it they were in the live chat
some people were commenting on my my
solution to make Adam faster or to at
least make it seem faster to me alright
so this step I'm not gonna lie this step
was what worried me the most
I was pretty sure that I'd be able to
figure these out easily and these went
really really well really fast not too
many issues the only issues and get
needs to work will really like either
misspellings or syntax errors on my part
so rendering it to the cards I'm going
to think out loud for a minute here to
see if we can you know let you know what
I'm thinking so you could give me some
some of your ideas and also just to make
it clear in my head so alright so we
have the data here
okay so within this this then okay we
need to do something with the data to
get it to hear right to render to to
fill out all of this stuff right now
this is getting in by this props data
you know filter now what I'm thinking
right off the bat and this certainly
wouldn't be it's never good encoding to
repeat yourself if you don't have to
right um right they said what is it they
call it dry dry coding do not repeat
right so anyway what I'm thinking right
off the bat is hey I could just like
copy this and instead of using this
props data I could use like whatever
variable I save this to right and then
somehow somehow we render okay so you
see maybe if you're good with react
you're probably wondering what the heck
I'm I'm thinking maybe it's obvious to
you but for me somehow the jump from the
jump from this data to filling this out
and so like completely removing
everything is here and then filling it
out again with other stuff that's the
jump that I'm having trouble thinking
about right now so normally a
this point I would just start trying
things and seeing what works and what
breaks and I would get there but since I
have all of you here watching as well
I'm going to check I'm just going to
give it just a few seconds here just
because the delay to see if anybody has
any better ideas about this before I
start just messing with things Oh in the
live chat mark recommends checking out
Visual Studio code I actually use that
as well so nice alright Fabien comes
through I was I was hoping that you were
still watching Fabien since since you
essentially wrote you know a lot of this
page with deal with that pull request
request that I emerged in yesterday I
was hoping that you would have some
insight into that so save the date of
the state it will trigger new run oh yes
now that you say that it makes so much
sense and this is this a good example of
like I wanted to really do this the
react way I certainly could have used
something like jQuery or even just
vanilla JavaScript to totally clear this
out and then add it but that's not
really what I want to do with react
because then react will lose track of
the Dom it react keeps a like a virtual
Dom where it has like a copy with a cut
do they call it the shadow Dom am i
confusing terms here anyway I can't
remember but anyway there's basically a
copy of the Dom that react keeps and it
needs to be able to keep track and keep
that in sync and if you start changing
things outside of react like in a
separate JavaScript file with jQuery or
something then they get out of sync okay
so then you won't really be taking
advantage of all the the goodness that
react has so anyway thank you Fabian
once again
okay John says it is virtual Dom okay so
I knew I've heard the term virtual DOM
and shadow Dom and for a minute I just
got it got it mixed up so what's what's
shadow Dom go with what am I thinking of
now I can't remember where I've heard
that before
all right I guess it doesn't really
matter for what we're doing right now so
um so we need to save
let me see we're saving this this stay
actually to tell you the truth I'm
looking at this and I'm still not sure
I'm still not 100% sure what I need to
do here because I'm pulling this data
and now is prop so it's going to props
when this anything in here when I return
data goes to props but if I want to save
the state when I need to pull it from
like this state data or am I just
missing something here let me know
all right we have some some references
to the movie Mad Max in the live chat
[Music]
that's funny in Orleans the shadow Dom
is for custom elements custom elements
mostly
okay bye so Fabian uh is saying in a
live chat yeah you state data instead of
perhaps data
well Jonathan and the lab chat also says
sublime
so it's referring to the editor sublime
we actually had I don't know how many
live streams that we've had a similar
conversation and it always does come up
the consensus is Adam load slowly
sublime is good and try visual studio
code occasionally we get some other ones
thrown in there but that seems to always
be the be consensus here if florian says
you could use a higher-order component -
Florian I like that suggestion I don't
know enough about higher-order
components to be confident doing that
though so if if anybody's wondering
about what a good way to do this would
be you could try out higher-order
component if you know more about that
but I want to learn more about it I just
don't know it now so that will be a
little bit beyond me at the point the
state
all right so let's see all right so
Florian saying or I'm sorry Fabian is
saying and knit the state with props
data on component did mount Oh awesome
great okay so basically here's what
here's we're going to do I'm going to
explain this out loud for everybody
watching but also so that I can verify
that I understand what Fabian saying you
can let me know so basically right now
the get initial props you know just by
default anything that you return from
this is going to be set to props
obviously right that's what it is
getting actual props right so that's why
down here I'm going this props data
right I'm getting this data but what
we're going to do is on component did
mount we're going to set this this data
so this props right and this props data
and we're going to set that to the state
so then when we come down here instead
of saying this props data we say this
state data and it will be the same thing
but that gives us then the ability to
change the state in here and then once
there's a change in state there it'll
automatically rerender all of this okay
so if that's not Fabian if that's not
what you had in mind let me know but I
think that's think that's what you're
trying to describe to me here and that
makes sense to me
Florian also says a higher-order
component is just a function which takes
a component as an argument and returns
another component and rhoann says google
dev resources has some good web
components and custom element stuff and
angular works well okay so Berlin still
talking about shadow DOM
okay so Fabian says the way I just
described it it seems right
Florian actually that's it that's a
really like nice simple explanation of a
higher-order component I think I am
going to check into those as soon as I
get a chance I'm not going to check into
it now
the stream because we're just so close
to getting this to work but thank you
for explaining that and I'm definitely
going to check it out also if you have
time and you would like to you're
certainly welcome to submit a pull
request to this repo with which you had
in mind with that too and in anybody
watching certainly you can if you'd like
to contribute that would be awesome but
otherwise I definitely do want to learn
more about higher order components on
how to use them because I've seen other
people do some useful things with them
so all right so now where my component
did mounts okay so this actually now
when I'm inside component did mount is
this going to mean what it should mean
or do any day use an arrow function here
too
[Music]
this doesn't exactly look right to me uh
I'm gonna try but let me let me know I
don't think I did this right
so oh I need to change it down here too
and let's see actually this is an
awesome way to do it I'll tell you one a
second okay so I'm going state here
right and down here though this
corresponds to this section here I don't
ever want this section to change even on
search right so this section will be
populated by props which is great and
then props will never change but the
state will change and when the state
changes it'll change all this stuff down
here but it will leave these alone so I
did think earlier when I was thinking
about this I thought I gotta have some
way to make sure that these don't change
and whoops didn't mean it like that
so that that will work that that'll
ensure that those stay the same but then
everything else changes
yeah thanks baby and I knew I was doing
that wrong so Fabian gave me the the
correct syntax for that so thank I knew
enough to know it wasn't right but I
didn't know enough to know the right way
to do it actually this kind of thing is
one of the reasons I was afraid to do
live streams at first because I don't
know how it seems to you but to me it
seems like it's really obvious what I
don't know and I was always nervous that
like everybody's going to see what a
newb I am but it's actually not that bad
I mean you are very helpful and nobody
is harassing me about being a noob and
I'm learning a lot of stuff and you know
these are things that I probably could
have spent time looking up and that
would have been fine that's a legit way
to do it but it would have taken me a
lot of time and I may have tried a lot
of other things and given up or tried
you know so I really it is really
beneficial even though I'm fully aware
that I probably look like a noob right
now alright so we've set it on component
amount next step is we need to update
the state that's it this set state all
right I totally remember using this at
some point in the past now that I see it
okay now we need to update the state
here with this data so I think Fabian
told me how to do it as well okay to
update the state you have to call set
state so let's just say this props it
okay so now I need to do let's get rid
of console.log so you need to do this
State and I'm assuming it's the same I
should just copy this while I'm not
trying to type this I'm assuming it's
the same syntax officer oh I'll find out
a second when I save this or if I'm
corrected in the live chat and data this
props dead now I don't want to diss
props data I want it to be data I'm
assuming this is not shoot I should
change this right well will this mess it
up but I'm using the same thing it
doesn't matter I was originally gonna
call this WP data anyway no to the beat
so I'll just go with that and then avoid
any potential for combat that actually
just makes it easier to read anyway so I
just double checking and
Oh actually oh nice
so Fabian and Florian both just let me
know I can just remove the I can remove
this this set state and actually since
I'm going to do that I might as well
just switch it back because now it'll no
longer be confusing at least to me it
was a little bit confusing this later on
or somebody else reading this I would
think that would be slightly confusing
if they weren't familiar with what I'd
already done alright so and they did
mention this is a es6 feature that this
just works to set this so like normally
like this is actually what we're doing
we're setting you know within this
object we're setting data to this props
data so that's what's happening it's as
if I just wrote data data right but I
don't have to and I assume that's
basically similar to what just happened
here as well that this goes to props you
know data data okay let me save it and
what I do this is T Oh
shoot I never did I said I said I was
going to probably have to do it and then
I never did it I'm assuming that that
error is because of this so I need to
use the arrow function if you didn't run
around when we talked about this before
this arrow function make sure that when
I use this here it means what I want it
to mean okay so basically it means the
same thing is when I call this within
the render function it's referring to
this as in like this this whole
component correct me if I'm wrong with
that but that's why we use the arrow
function in that case maybe it didn't
work maybe that wasn't the issue I
should think
unless you restart the server I think I
froze my local server not still give me
the error okay what do I done oh okay
Ally says bind it within then that makes
sense all right so I'm trying to use
this within then so I should use that
there as well all in Florida Florian I
said the same thing and giving me the
syntax
I like that syntax that's going to look
a lot cleaner too so let's see
let me get rid of all this stuff and
instead put this in here great okay so
we see we have then data right so we
have that whereas before I should have
left the other one up so I could compare
between the two but basically what would
normally go in the the function like in
the brackets where we have the function
just goes here we have this arrow the
arrow function here and now we're just
doing this set state data and now this
will mean what we want it to mean
hopefully hopefully it'll work I just do
okay I'm still getting this up here
though let me just let me take a better
look at this and see component in mom do
I need to hmm
okay let me I'm looking at this you all
can see this - sure so basically I know
that this was probably too small let me
blow up this error so you can see what
I'm saying wow that's too big no okay
so unexpected character here why am I
getting an unexpected character
you
this is 37 yeah 37 for
okay this is going to seem weird but I'm
just going to do this uh the only reason
I'm doing this just to see like maybe
something here is messing this up I I
don't think it would be but that's why
I'm just flipping this to the top just
to see if I get the same error okay so
I'm still getting an unexpected
character but now it's this time it's
online
okay so now I'm getting a not read
property filter undefined 155 all right
let's check this up
hmm
way too soon
oh okay alright so basically this is
what's happening
well not fabian has pointed out in the
live chat that this is what's happening
so i don't want to take credit for
figuring this out basically like it
showed this line here that it was
showing was like right where we're
trying to have the tabs i'm not going to
go back down but basically like the tabs
that we're going across the page that we
we could click so i'm going to do with
that so fabian saying now you also need
to in its state like that state equals
active tab all data because the first
render might bug if state data is not
defined
okay so let's find where we add these
[Music]
so if active state
equals active to all data
all right yes at the top okay
let's just double checking before I put
it in there so uh here then let's see
state equals I'm just gonna copy so I'm
assuming here shoot
let me know if I put this in the right
spot this doesn't look right again I'm
pretty sure I didn't put that baby in
says lol no alright so I so I knew that
wasn't right um my pudding at this point
Fabian is like um I feel like he's my
coach here okay so I'm scrolling baby's
selling me scroll up so when I when he
said at the top I thought he meant like
at the top of this render function and
then I pasted there and obviously that
wasn't the right spot so now I'm going
scrolling up more let's see
yes statisticians
before okay that's what I was waiting
Sebastian says before get initial props
oh I see it now I see it thanks
Sebastian
okay so now I'm pretty sure what I have
to do is add it in here oops not like
that
[Music]
need to add it here so basically the
only thing that's that's added so we
already had this and then we're adding
data all right okay that makes that
makes so much sense now um sorry sorry
about that taking so long that process
so yeah obviously this makes sense okay
so our state's an object we were you
know we need this data so we already had
active tab set right down here we were
setting data to actually have the value
okay but Fabian saying we might get a
bug if we don't have a state data
defined beforehand that makes a lot of
sense let's save it
okay and there's some discussion going
on a live chat about constructors and
es7 and initializing state and I'm not
I'm gonna I'm gonna wait and see what
the conclusion is to that discussion if
it happens before I before I read out
what's going on um all right let me
check what happened here whoa that's
crazy what the heck just somehow anyway
I don't I accidentally just assumed that
into 200 I don't oh I know a zoomed in
and whenever we had the error and then I
didn't dream it back out so anyway so
that page loaded and we're not getting
these are like the normal errors that I
always get when I'm on the dev server so
I'm not worried about that and now let's
check great okay so that should give us
nothing that was kind of an abrupt
change there I mean just from like a
style design standpoint like I I don't
like that that changed and then I went
like that so I don't know maybe I'll
have to think of something else to put
there but let's let's see like I'm gonna
I'm just going to type in this woman's
last name because that will probably be
unique and we'll see like that this is
just going to give us this there we go
so it actually gave us that before I
didn't have to take the whole name in
but you can see that's really fast that
search happens so fast and that's I mean
that request has to go to WordPress and
be processed
you know WordPress is based on PHP you
know it has a database so I mean that
all has to to be processed and come back
and it just happens very fast
I mean this is not I'm not getting this
data from something on my local machine
this is actually going right to the
WordPress install that's on digital
ocean and back so I don't I don't know
about you but I'm just impressed with
the speed of this search and when I've
done this before like I've never done in
react but I've done it with jQuery
before and I have had you know clients
and other people I worked with have been
really impressed with that speed so if
you're using the WordPress API I
definitely recommend doing something
like this because like I set up clients
have always been impressed with first of
all the fact that it Auto searches when
you're typing in right I mean yeah
Google search does that but people
expect Google to have impressive things
because they're huge company with lots
of money and employees and a lot of
talented people but you know when a
small business or something when you do
a site for them and now they see that
they have a similar kind of thing happen
they're very impressed with that they
like that at least that's been my
experience so they're impressed that it
Auto searches and they're impressed with
how fast the search comes up one of my
to do's I don't know if you caught it
but when I showed you my original code
that I done with jQuery you know a long
time ago I had a bunch of to do is one
of the two do's was to add some sort of
loader so that when people are waiting
it just it shows this little loader the
reason I never put it in is because no
one ever had to wait for longer than you
know basically it always loaded in such
a short amount of time the loader would
only appear for a split second and it
wouldn't it wouldn't even matter so
before I kind of stopped this I do want
to give credit here so I know we
basically completely redid this and
react but since I showed you this
initial code that I had done this is
where I got it from so if I do get some
code from somewhere I always want to
make sure that I I give credit even if I
don't really have to based on the
license I still like to but this is
where I got it so github calm so it's
bearded Avenger
on github so I've never talked to this
person or contacted them or anything and
this was this code originally was was
for the WordPress API version 1 which I
never used version 1 because I didn't
start using the API until version 2 had
it had just come out when I started
using it so I did have to change this to
work with version 2 but the basic idea
of this live search came from here so if
you did want to do something like this
on a site that was you know let's say
based on jQuery and wasn't react you
know then check out that code but it
will need to be adapted from version 1
I don't know last time I checked I think
there were some pull requests for people
trying to adapt it as well but I don't
know that this is maintained so I don't
think any of those pull requests ever
got accepted so I was thinking about
doing a pull request as well but I don't
think they're updating it so it probably
wouldn't be they probably would never
get merged in so so basically that works
with like I said there were some
optimizations I wanted to do I wanted to
slow it down a little so it didn't make
API requests for every single key up
event like if they are coming really
really quickly so with the exception of
that which would simply you know I would
just need like a set timeout on the like
here where we have yet search results
you know we would just need a set
timeout and that's I mean that said it
wouldn't be much more than that and I
would also need something in here too
like let's say check every time the key
up went up it would check the value and
if the length of the value was greater
than 2 it would search otherwise it
would do nothing so basically the whole
thing would be in an if statement that
would check for that and then it would
also have a set timeout that would be
I don't know some some amount of
milliseconds that I would have to mess
with so other than that it's pretty much
done I did mention I saw like the change
was pretty abrupt when you have nothing
so it has like this job I just don't
like that jump so maybe I'll just have
it might be something as simple as just
setting a minimum height for this
section so that I don't have such a
drastic drop here that'll probably fix
it that'll be a really simple fix I
don't think I need anything fancy for
this actually let me just try that out
right now in the inspector so for for
everybody who's more front-end like kind
of basics oriented maybe this will be
something simple for you all and as soon
as I do this I'm going to go back to the
live chat I'm going to check and see if
there's any questions and I'm going to
answer the questions and also share
anything that's maybe some really
valuable advice on the live chat that I
haven't shared already so if you're just
here for the live the live search
portion of this I mean that's pretty
much done we've done everything we
needed to so if you got to go thanks for
watching I'm on you know Monday through
Friday 2:00 p.m. Eastern Time
almost always occasionally I have a
meeting or something happens and I can't
stream but you know joint join me again
I'll be doing all kinds of different
stuff for the site and for other sites
in the future if you have a little bit
of time to stick around for some
questions or anything go ahead and throw
your questions in the live chat now and
then I'll get to as soon as I'm done
with this if you can't stick around you
have a question put it in the comments
below or you can direct message me on
Twitter the link to my Twitter is in the
description for this video all right so
this is yeah this is the section let's
go with a min height of 500 pixels mmm
actually it's got more let me do like
700 pixels oops what did I do here and
now it's not even ice it's not letting
me edit that which is weird what are you
doing to me dev tools I'm going to
refresh because I can't edit that ok
alright so min height and the skill is
700 pixels ok because I'm okay with that
because the section is always going to
be like normally really big it's only
going to get smaller if I type in
nonsense hmm I don't know that I like
I'm I don't think I like that still let
me try that again
that's better
ok that that's definitely better than it
was I'm not sure that I want this to go
down though so what I have here is this
is now this is via line so I'm going to
take out that class and this I'm using
materializes the framework and they have
this vertical line class is going to set
up already
and maybe I'll have to you have to take
this out as well see if that does it
there we go ok so that did it so
assuming this doesn't change anything
else that's better that's what I wanted
okay so you see the transition I don't
know if you saw it or if it bugged you
all as much as above me but before the
transition was much more abrupt the
footer actually came all the way up here
ok and now it still looks the same
normally as it did but then we change it
the footer actually you know you see it
a little bit but it's not a huge jump
you can see we have
this still stays at the top I might
actually remove this in the background
I'm not sure if I like it for a big
section like that I didn't notice it
before behind all these cards it was
kind of down here I don't know I'll
think about it
I think about it for that section
it doesn't look terrible when you have a
lot of cards but you don't have any
cards is more noticeable and yeah I
don't know about it also not sure about
this having a white background I might
like it better if it didn't say I mean
those are some really like little CSS
changes like some design changes so I'm
not going to bother with those right now
make you wait around for that but I am
I'm definitely going to put this keep
this min height in for the section and
take out those two things there's two
classes that I did all right so now let
me go to the live chat I'm going to
scroll through I don't think I'm going
to go all the way to the top because I
did do a good job of checking back in
I'm going to go about to the middle of
where the live chat is now and just see
if I've missed anything who also I will
I do have to double check that this
fetch works in older browsers and so
there might be some adjustments made as
soon as that this goes I haven't pushed
this to github yet but as soon as it's
on github you'll be able to see the code
and then you'll be able to check back in
you know maybe tomorrow next week and
see if I did have to edit it if I do
have to edit it and change it in any way
like if I test it and it doesn't work on
some others I'll let you know and one of
the streams but I'm thinking this should
work basically without any changes
okay Taylor Miller says I really
appreciate your stream everyone has
things they don't know or others may be
no better ways of doing things thanks
for streaming and sharing your thoughts
/ process with us oh you're welcome and
thanks for that comment I really
appreciate that comments like that they
let me know that what I'm doing as value
and I should keep doing it so I know I
said this before but I'll keep doing
these videos as long as as my boss keeps
letting me do them which he's he's happy
with with me doing them now so that's
probably not going to change and as long
as I think people find value in them so
if you do find value in this you know
let me know and I'll keep doing
okay so scrolling down through making
sure I didn't miss anyone's questions
okay Florian says do you use debounce or
do you send every time you enter
character requests yeah so right now
okay so you already answered him but
yeah right now it's on every key but I
definitely don't want it to stay like
that okay
Sebastian asks if you delete the value
from the input what will be displayed
and Rohan answered everything I guess
yeah and it is everything so you'll see
right now I have a value in there but if
I delete it it actually displays
everything I will have to so I had
mentioned before I want it to not work
uh if there's only like one or two
characters there I want there to have to
be three or more characters for this to
work so when I do implement that then
taking everything out won't work because
it won't do anything if there's fewer
than three characters so I didn't think
about that but I like the fact that it
reloads when there's nothing
so what I'll probably have to do is in
that that if statement it'll be like if
the length of the input value is greater
than 2 or 0 then it will do it will do
the search it'll get the the data
otherwise it won't do anything although
I am I am a little bit in I'm interested
in how how I'm getting
okay that's how I just was thinking like
if I'm searching for nothing then why is
it returning everything so that must be
the default so if you see it's probably
hard to see because it's small up here
but I said I just manually did this put
in a search term and I I put in nothing
so basically the same thing that would
be put in right now and then I made the
call on nothing and the default is that
for WordPress the default is if you
search for nothing it returns everything
right so that means if if your search
string is literally you know nothing has
no characters in it you'll get that so
good to know and thanks for bringing
that up Sebastian because I totally
didn't think about that issue and I'll
have to make sure that I add that in
florian says you could use a debounce
function would be much easier okay
I've +1 for devout Patrick okay I've
never even heard of you do balance
function so I'm gonna look that up and
it seems like seems like you all think
that's the way to go
fabien ass how do you do the bounce
function with rxjs or something else and
florian responded no just plain J s you
could find one easily on Google if
you're interested in how it works but if
you want to use it just import it from
lodash and Patrick gave me a link to the
bounce function from David Walsh's blog
awesome Fabian thanks I'm going to check
out that link all Sebastian says got the
answer for my question so you you saw
that when it happened then Roland says
you can animate the height to min height
so it's even less abrupt oh that's a
good idea maybe I'll try that I'll have
to let you know I'm actually I'm getting
to the point in this project where I
think I think it's time for me to move
on to other projects soon so and by that
I mean like people higher up than they I
think are expecting that me to move on
to other projects soon so I mean I
showed you you all seen the Trello board
there's still quite a lot of stuff on
here I've started moving things over to
this column and it's like stuff that I
kind of thought I might want to do but
now that I think about it it doesn't
really need to happen because so
basically like I need to get a move on
with this and either get some stuff done
or figure out what doesn't really need
done
so the reason I say that is just simply
like row on I I really I think the
animate height is a good idea animate
height to min height but little details
like that I love little details like
that and I want to put it in but at this
point I may have to decide like what
should I spend my time on now something
like that probably only take like a few
minutes to implement so maybe that'll
actually end up in there as well but I
do need to start thinking like okay I
know what I want to do to make this site
like really good how I really want it
but realistically like is it worth
my time to do that when there are a lot
of other projects that are very
important as well that need done so also
the fact that there's not really a lot
of traffic on the site is causing me to
rethink some of the priorities for the
site like this site was very important
because of the the people who had been
told about this site we're really you
know important people for this
university so it needed to be done but
now like I'm kind of thinking you know
there are some other sites you know like
right now this site gets I don't know
hundreds a few hundred views and most of
that are from you all I mean there are
sites I could be working on they get in
the millions of views and that would
probably have a bigger impact so so if
you see me in one of my upcoming streams
switch to a different project and you
wonder why I've left some of these
things undone that's probably that's why
so I'm not exactly code related but
these are things that I guess you have
to think about depending on you know
what type of work you're doing and you
know at some point you do just kind of
have to say like you know I I want to
make this project as good as it can be
but you have to stop you know you could
like continually enhance a site forever
there has to be some some pointers stuff
and so for this site I'm getting close
to the point where I think I could stop
and for the from the users point of view
the site would be a complete experience
I know they're probably they're always
things you could do better you know from
a developer point of view but really
like from a user's perspective this site
does look complete already it functions
well there's not very many things more
than someone I think would expect
reasonably from this site so I just need
to add in those few extra things maybe
and then kind of assess where I'm at
the next project is alright I think
we're almost to the end of the live chat
all of our asks I'm new here should I
learn angular angular 2/4 or react he
says or are they all are they basically
the same Oliver I am angular and react
aren't the same I've heard to explain
like this basically angular is angular
is like a fool MVC framework writes
model-view-controller a framework write
react would just be the V part of the
MVC so the view part so so I don't think
react and angular are directly
comparable in that way
I have minimal minimal work with angular
so I'm not a really good judge between
them I've seen really good projects
built with both of them and I I know
they're really good developers that use
one or the other or even both so I know
this is not much of an answer but it
will kind of depend on what you're
working on and what you like you know
certainly if you try them I'd say try
and both try to do just basic projects
in both and see what you like more
because regardless of which one's better
if they're both similar you know so one
maybe is just a little better than the
other for what you're doing but you
really like working with one a lot more
you should go with that one because if
you're going to be spending hours and
hours and hours you know every day you
want to be doing something that you like
or else it's you know it's going to be
miserable for you so anyway that's my
answer maybe you all have
answer to that question but like I said
I don't know I haven't built a lot of
things with angular actually I don't
think I've ever built anything that
actually worked with angular I worked
with angular when it like years ago when
it was somewhat newer and I worked on a
project for a while and it was just it
broke and I couldn't get it to work and
I eventually just abandoned it so so I'm
not a good judge of angular and it
wasn't angular's fault it was my
inexperience
so I Rowland says I like your series I
don't know react and I really had no
intention to learn it but I guess I will
now oh that's cool
yeah I mean I'm not like I'm not an
advocate of any you know framework or
anything I just I started using react I
like react I like the results I get with
it and I think it's fun to work with so
yes and try it out okay keV Ian says it
sounds like a proverb or something like
that and then he's quoting me from
earlier if you search for nothing you
will get everything yeah when you say it
like that it does sound like a proverb
if you search nothing good ever
I have to think about that and see if it
makes any sense at all aside from the
context of the wordpress API I'm not
sure right now if that if that could be
applied to any other thing it actually
makes sense
Roland says you do need a hard
breakpoint on a project otherwise as
designers or developers you try to keep
on adding new stuff to it stuff that you
the user otherwise wouldn't even expect
that's a really good point that that
last part of stuff that the user
otherwise wouldn't even expect I'm yeah
let me talk about that for a second
because I think that's a great point
as developers were like we know more of
what's out there on websites and was
possible I think that is really good
advice to to keep in mind the average
user doesn't have that same level of
understanding the possibilities of what
what you can do with websites right I
mean as developers like we we watch
videos of the latest stuff from like you
know conferences and things and you know
we know what's out there so I think at
least I know from my perspective I'm I'm
hard on myself sometimes because I know
a lot of this really awesome stuff that
people are doing and when my sites don't
do that I a part of me feels like the
site's not good because it's not doing
the awesome stuff that I've seen other
people do but when I show it to other
people like other people that I work
with or family or friends I often get a
really positive response not always I
mean I'm not going to say everybody
always loves everything I do but some I
usually get a positive response and
people like wow this is great and I
don't always understand it and I'm not
I'm not usually like always as satisfied
with my work as other people are so I
think it's good to keep in mind that the
average user has I want to say like much
lower expectations than developers I
don't want it to sound bad like but I
think it's simply because that's not
their field you know everybody in their
own particular field of what they work
on they're going to know more about it
you know they're gonna I don't know I
guess I could look at a painting and
think it's awesome and then an artist
could look at a painting and realize all
the stuff that's wrong with it and what
should have happened you know
same way like you know a chef would look
at a meal in a different way than
someone who's not a chef right and be
able to critique it so anyway thanks for
that Rohan that was really
be insightful of you I'm gonna have to
keep that in mind for me as well um our
patch says which language should I move
on Java or Python I'm struggling to find
which one to opt for and Rohan responded
our PES if you are talking about college
take Java and learn Python by yourself
ok I don't have a lot of experience with
Python or Java my my advice on which
language to learn is usually based on
what do you want to do with it so some
things like as far as I know Android
apps are built with Java so if let's say
you really really want to build Android
apps maybe Java is the way to go or if
there's a company that you really like
it's your dream to work for that company
and you know that they primarily use one
language over another do that otherwise
if you don't have any you know any goals
like that then maybe you should go with
you know maybe look at which language
has more jobs you know that's that's a
legitimate reason to go with it is you
know just check it out and then finally
what do you enjoy using more so you know
trying both out a little bit and then
see which one you like and that that's
my advice for that I have worked
slightly with Java and Python Java was
so long ago I really don't even remember
much about it but Python the thing I
really loved about Python I think I
might have mentioned this last week at
some point thing I loved about Python is
the syntax is like mostly based off of
indentation so it was really easy for me
to code with Python on my phone normally
the way the keyboards are on phones it's
really hard to put in a lot of the
special
characters you know : semicolons and
quotation marks like they're not really
like right there available but with
Python I didn't need a lot of those
things so I was able to do like a lot of
I don't know like small like algorithm
challenges with Python and complete them
like when I was like laying in bed at
night before I went to sleep I would do
a couple of algorithm challenges in
Python right from my phone I really
liked that I thought that was cool once
I started to get like into more complex
algorithms it wasn't as doable on my
phone but basic stuff the the intro to
computer science course from Udacity
uses Python and that's the course I was
taking at the time and that's what I was
using my phone for so I know that's
that's pretty silly reason to like a
language but I thought it was cool
Oliver Oliver says in response to our
pestis question about Java and Python
Java is harder but faster Python and it
was productivity personally I really
like Python hey Rohan says personally I
use Python regularly and love it Java is
important and good but I don't really
like the verbosity of it I like the Java
VM but the language not very much says
yup Java is faster than Python leaps and
bounds faster and then Jesse nice name
by the way
Jesse oak okiya I'm not sure I pronounce
the last name I'm sorry about that says
I've been playing around with react for
a while but I'm having difficulties with
react router Dom it returns a 404 when I
go directly to the link do you know any
good documentation or boilerplate to get
me started with I wish I knew more I
haven't worked with react router enough
and I don't know I would say if you
aren't already using this try to go with
um one of the reactive other plates that
are popular like create react app is
actually from Facebook and you could try
that one
and maybe that would be easier I haven't
used in a long time I know there's been
a lot of updates I tried it like when it
first came out and I haven't tried it
since so I don't know for sure how good
that is or you can try next which is
what I'm using for this project and then
that handles a lot of the routing for
you I guess it just depends on what you
need it for so so sorry I don't have a
better answer for you in terms of
documentation but I I do like next it is
somewhat opinionated in in terms of like
the default router you know you have to
have a different JavaScript file in the
pages folder but if you see I don't know
if you saw the video or we did some
custom routes in our server JS file and
so that we could have parameterize
routes for like our blog style news page
so maybe check that out I don't remember
what I called the video but it was
something to do a custom routing and
parameterize routing I think I called it
so maybe check that out just to see how
you do routing with next with like the
custom routing and see if that would
solve your issue and if it would then
maybe go with next otherwise I haven't
had a lot of experience with with the
react router to be able to to give you a
lot of help with it okay kevin has some
good advice as well so says you need to
configure your server to serve index on
every request web pack dev server has it
config for it if you are using that okay
awesome
actually let me since we're talking
about it I'll just bring up my server is
just so that you all can see this I'm
not really going to comment on it too
much but just in case anyone's
interested how how I set up moves to
diso 'pn
where did this open it
oops I get open on this side yeah it did
okay so um yeah this is how I have liked
some of the routes set up so like I said
I'm not I've done a video where we kind
of went over some of this so this is how
I've set up so this is if you wanted to
do some custom routing and use next at
the same time this I do it so next
routing with these pages still works but
then we also have some other stuff going
on where we pass you know some you know
the the end of the URL there you know we
pass that and we make API calls based on
that so mmm our page says okay thanks a
lot for Java in college and learn Python
on the side awesome and if you if you
watch our pêche if you're watching any
other live streams in the future let us
know how things are going with the Java
and the Python and I mean I'm I don't
really do Java Python on this live
stream I don't have to do it at work but
still it would be cool to be cool to
hear how things are going with you know
trying to learn some other languages and
Kevin says in response to Jesse's
question webpack dev server okay so it's
giving a like a command so I'm not going
to read out the command and probably not
useful to read that out but but thanks I
love I love that everybody is really
kind of helping each other out in the
live chat I think it's awesome
also actually some some people from you
live chat earlier started in an IRC
channel for this so let me let me grab
this link and put it in here
so I'm like super new with IRC so I'm
not exactly sure how to do everything
but if you're you know better with it
you know feel free to join um this is
the the channel just to kind of talk I
am NOT on here all the time but I kind
of try to leave it open when I can and
so if anybody wants to chat and help
each other out you know you can go ahead
and check out that channel as well
Rowland does say if you really want to
go tough on yourself and your college
has it go for C++ you'll probably hate
it in the beginning but you'll find
everything easier afterwards hi that's
20 the only programming course that I
ever actually finished in college was a
C++ course and the only thing I remember
doing from that course is a calculator
so I did really well in the class I just
I don't remember very much about C++ but
the basic concepts of like loops and
things like that
boolean's I remember those and those
helped when I later on was getting into
JavaScript more Tony Raines says I'm
currently in in uni so for everybody in
the United States University it's uni so
in the United States they don't say uni
but so just in case you don't know that
is and I know Java Python and learning
j/s JavaScript what do you think I
should be prioritizing right now should
I go to like SQL c-sharp or what hmm
my thing is it kind of depends on what
you want to do if you want to go like
full-stack and you're learning like some
of the JavaScript stuff you know learn
some database stuff and and then you can
pick up some HTML and CSS and then you
know you basically you know have a nice
like full stack skill set if you really
want to keep going for it I think that
would be that would be cool
Tony said he's sorry Canadian don't
apologize for it I just I mean I I knew
what it meant mostly just because of
watching people from other countries on
YouTube
i watch a lot of cooking shows on
YouTube and they're usually always
people from other countries so anyway I
just wanted to help out people who may
not know what that have meant so no need
to apologize
oh cool our pest says I'll keep you
updated about my small adventure thank
you awesome I appreciate that Patrick
says when I did my CS degree I wrote
plenty of Java but opted for C whenever
I had the choice because it was harder
ya see so I started taking the cs50
computer science course from Harvard
it's like their their online course that
a ton of people take they you see like
at the begin of different languages but
one of the languages they use a C and
that's the first I've ever been exposed
to like you're just basic old-school C
and it definitely made me appreciate
JavaScript and other like kind of more
modern languages because it's definitely
is harder it's harder to even do like
basic things
so yeah you appreciate things patrick
said and it gives you more experience of
that computer actually works totally
agree
tony says yeah I'm trying to learn
JavaScript HTML CSS all at once right
now also trying to throw in some SQL and
and yeah I guess all right awesome glad
glad I could help a little bit actually
I want to ask you guys this because I've
heard it different ways do you say SQL
or do you say sequel let me know
and I'd like to say it the right way and
not sound like a noob but as I've said
before I don't know if you know there's
not really it's pretty much me and like
one other person that does all the stuff
here and we're both very much like you
know learning as we go so I don't have a
lot of people to talk to about this so I
don't ever act I don't ever hear these
terms spoken out loud okay Patrick says
sequel alright I like to say sequel but
occasionally I'll say sequel to somebody
and they look at me really funny like
what are you talking about okay Rohan
says SQL that's cute
okay all right so I guess there's a
mixer I get it's I I guess it's
acceptable to say it either way SQL or
sequel thanks for the feedback Jessie
says thanks a lot guys that was really
helpful awesome I'm glad we could help
Rohan says lower level language isn't
usually practical practical but you get
a lot more insight as to stuff how it
works on how stuff works underneath oh
yeah totally agree Rohan Morel into the
basic sequel isn't that hard usually
yeah I haven't had to work with sequel
directly very often I've done like in
the context of WordPress I've like
manually copied some databases and
things like that I've done that from the
command line before and also through
like like the PHP my admin panel so I've
done that either way yeah it wasn't that
difficult to do it's just a little a
little different but nothing the Google
search couldn't solve so it didn't take
me that long to do it and actually the
hardest part was I had something weird
with like the table names were like
we're off so that was like my problem
that took me a long time if I had just
double-checked the table names were
corrective it would have taken me like
no time at all
okay Patrick's although Patrick says
sequel he also says Postgres SQL so
either way so anyway yeah the consensus
seems to be that there is no consensus
on how to say sequel or SQL Jessie asked
MongoDB or sequel which do you think is
more productive I'm not going to be able
to answer this one myself because I
don't have enough experience with
databases so maybe someone else in the
live chat can answer or I'm probably
going to end this stream pretty soon
because this has been a super long
stream very productive but long and I
need to yeah I wanted to solve the store
before I got home and I'm feeling super
tired right now so I'm going to wrap it
up soon so if anybody has some good
advice on between MongoDB and sequel 4
for Jesse
you know put it down in the and I'm not
speaking in and like what it called in
the third person here first four so
Jesse okay it's a different Jesse in the
live chat in case you're watching this
later and don't can't see the name but
anyway if you have any advice or
responses to any of the questions we've
been going over and you're watching this
later when it's recorded you know put
some put some answers in the comments I
read the comments for sure and I imagine
some of the other people in the live
stream a live chat read the comments so
that would be awesome and then you know
you could join in even though you can't
make it when it's live row on says not
much experience but either but no sequel
can be hard in many cases to implement
[Music]
let's see I'm sorry I'm not sure to
pronounce this name I apologize if I
mess it up
Mamadou sorry says MongoDB is a s GBD
and sequel is a request language I'm not
exist and source so
I'm not really sure what maybe you could
put the okay so sorry I can't speak
English very well oh that was fine I
could I mean I could understand it I
just don't know what that acronym means
Umberto says one of the main reasons one
of the main questions to ask is whether
you know the structure of your data to
begin with krong krong is says have you
tried firebase I haven't tried firebase
I'm not sure if that was directed at
Jessie for his question about databases
then I don't really know but okay I am
since a minute ago I checked the time
and realized how late it was
I'm going to wrap this up so I got to go
to the store I one of my co-workers
really had my back and turned in my
credit card statements for me when I was
sick last week and so I promised her
that I would pay her back and she
requested that I cook something so in
case you didn't know I happen to be a
good cook but so anyway so she saw I
made some stuff on my Instagram and she
requested so I have to go to the store
and pick that up before I go home and
anyway this was this was awesome this
was something setting up the live
there's too many things live one on it
uh I'm going to say setting up the live
search was something that I Cana was
like I thought it might take a long time
to really do it the right way and react
and this didn't take very much time at
all thanks to your help I really
appreciate that you hope I would not
have been able to accomplish what I did
today if it weren't for you all that was
awesome so
I'm going to Wow Rohan sorry Rowan said
it's 2:00 a.m. here we've been up for 22
hours Wow okay I'm definitely ending
this dream so Rohan can go to sleep so
Wow
that's dedication thanks for staying up
late and and watching this yes all right
so thank you for watching I should be
back tomorrow like I said I'm still not
feeling very well but hopefully I'll
feel well enough to come into work
tomorrow and I'll do the stream and I
said any any questions or anything you
didn't get asked throw it in the
description or throw it in the comments
below or direct message me on Twitter
thanks for watching and have a great day